jane you've been in this business uh
quite a while you've had so much success
uh in in film and i you know just
different iconic roles you're always
funny and i'm just curious
what was your first job in front of the
camera like we all have to start
somewhere
i did uh and i've i've mentioned this
before
but i remember the first job i got was
actually doing industrial
uh footage yeah i think that was the
first thing i did you remember the first
thing that you did
yes the first thing i did in front of a
camera was a home shopping show
and it was right when they were starting
it was called america's shopping place
it would have been in the
probably the mid 80s and it was 24 hours
of television shopping uh programming
and i was on the
2 a.m to 5 a.m
the coveted slot exactly and
we took phone calls we took live
phone calls in the middle of the night
of people buying
cubic zirconia and i learned so much
about being on my feet
and dealing with uncomfortable
situations and
yeah i learned a lot learned a lot about
improvising and they were trying to
replace me too the whole time because i
wasn't your typical
you know uh kind of home shopping person
and so i would audition my replacements
wait they wouldn't be on the air they
would audition people they wanted to
maybe replace you with in front of you
in front of me and i would help them of
course being the nice catholic girl go
oh this is how you do it you you read
from this book but make sure you
your eyes are on the camera and you look
down and you grab a line and then you
look at the camera and
i gave her all the tricks of the trade
that does sound very much like you let
me help you destroy my career
very nice of you